Have you
seen these images
coming out of Azerbaijan?
A hundred thousand
people have fled their homes.
Let me show you on the map
why this has happened.
We're talking about a region up here.
It's called the Caucasus,
these two countries,
Azerbaijan and Armenia.
There's been a lot of tension
between these two about borders,
which is why you have all these enclaves.
One of these borders is right here.
The region of Nagorno-Karabakh.
Ethnic Armenians
have lived here for decades
and have been trying
to make their own state
within Azerbaijan.
Azerbaijan has tried
to drive them out for decades.
But Russia, who's just right up here,
has been the one kind
of keeping the peace,
keeping stability between the two.
But Russia has turned its attention
towards its war in Ukraine.
So Azerbaijan,
with the support of their neighbor
Turkey, has kicked out
almost everyone in this enclave
and pushed them into Armenia.
And that's what we're looking at
in this imagery.
All of this is a sign of Russia's
waning influence in the Caucasus
and an increase of Turkey's
influence there.
If you want to better understand
international politics, follow for more.